monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale
sur la suppression de centaines de
classes en milieu rural vous avez
répondu monsieur le ministre par des
chiffres diminution du nombre d'élèves
taux d'encadrement ratio et en même
temps la priorité d'améliorer les
conditions d'enseignement et
d'encadrement en même temps le candidat
est aujourd'hui président Macron déclaré
il n'y aura plus de fermeture de classe
sans Laval du maire mais Monsieur le
Ministre la réalité tout autre vous
appliquez des critères qui accélèrent la
fermeture des classes et des cols
rurales avec la suppression de 2000
postes et en même temps le soutien à la
ruralité est affiché comme une priorité
par les ministres forts et Béchu les
mers des territoires demandent une
concertation promise depuis plusieurs
mois la prise en compte de contraintes
territoriales avec la définition d'un
indice d'éloignant et la spécificité des
classes multi-âge pourquoi quand vous
poursuivez le dédoublement des classes
en zone sensible prioritaire le monde
rural doit payer le début d'une approche
comptable déséquilibrée l'école rurale
est une chance pour nos enfants car il
conjugue proximité qualité de
l'enseignement la ruralité nos petites
communes sont aussi des zones sensibles
prioritaires et doivent aussi bénéficier
du débit dédoublement des classes alors
je vous le demande monsieur le ministre
un moratoire sur la fermeture des
classes et école en milieu rurale
[Applaudissements]